so I'd say my favorite thing about being
a Jew is controlling the banks and the
media but besides that I really like
it's a culture of questioning and I like
all the questions that surround this and
and I think the four questions are
probably my favorite part of Passover
and and and usually the youngest and the
family asks those four questions I used
to be the youngest and so I would ask
them but now that I'm no longer the
youngest I thought it would be cool to
bring in my youngest my youngest son to
come in and maybe do the 4 questions
himself hey Nick is going good Finn how
are you son I'm good you gotta stop
calling me your son okay can I say that
I'm your co-star in stranger things and
well yeah it won't be true but yeah you
could do that okay great so are you
ready to sing before questions ah I
don't
thanks I mean I don't even know the four
questions well I I look I don't actually
know them very well myself I just used
to sing you know Hakuna Matata and then
and then my grandfather would cry and
embarrassment so I you let me help you
Oh piano oh me oh yeah you're not the
youngest though I can log off kid
[Music]
- tada Lila is it me call me
ha ha
[Music]
guru maha shiva for Haleh out on you
Alicia
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I miss you miss you be happy face up
everybody that's the way it's done mic
drop
I'm out